donald trump never got the chance to
breathe
as president democrats deep staters and
never trump grifters
all played a role in this nefarious
effort
because they did everything in their
power didn't they to drive him out of
office long before he was sworn in
they illegally surveilled his campaign
smeared him as a russian agent
forced him to spend millions of dollars
in legal fees
threatened his family dragged out the
ridiculous mueller investigation
impeached him for talking to the
president of ukraine
and when all that failed they moved on
to blaming him for covet
then for the riots after george floyd's
death
and every step of the way the
small-minded men and women who make up
the american left in the american press
corps
were complicit that donald trump
is a criminal enterprise
a presidency in peril as we learn more
about the mueller investigation the
walls are closing in on president trump
and his inner circle
it seems that donald trump by
mishandling kovitz
so badly has branded himself as
incompetent
this is not the first time that donald
trump has fallen short of being a leader
he has routinely called for violence and
stoked the racial tensions in this
country
oh my god that was painful to watch well
early on trump pegged them
as fake news didn't he and he refused to
suck
up to them like so many other
politicians and at some point along the
way
reporters and producers who were once
kind of semi-reasonable
just became complete and utter partisan
hacks
their playbook consisted of downplaying
or ignoring trump's many achievements
and hyping baseless allegations without
any
objective corroboration against him then
by the fall
democrats on the hill and in newsrooms
across the country
had an urgent cleanup operation on their
hands
and at that point they began to engage
in a massive cover-up for joe biden's
family
which had profited of course handsomely
from the sun from sun hunters unusual
business
dealings abroad a computer store owner
who had possession of his laptop came
forward and
emails began to leak out after the new
york post broke the story and began
publishing hunter's emails
only a few major outlets like fox took
it all seriously
turns out actual dollar figures for
hunter's chinese consultancy
had been discussed apparently with his
father's blessing
one email mentioned a specific dollar
amount set aside for the
big guy who was widely thought to be joe
biden himself
well this is when the biden campaign
surrogates began circling the wagons
it appeared in a tabloid that president
trump and his allies are really trying
to seize on it's a series of buzzwords
that have meaning
perhaps if you've been studying uh you
know
the daily caller or whatever it is this
is an example of steve bannon giving a
tip
to a new york post reporter rudy
giuliani handing over a bunch of
documents and then fox running with it
for days on
end creating this appearance of a
scandal involving hunter biden
are they that unself-aware creating an
appearance
of a scandal what he just said is all
they tried to do for four years against
president trump
we now know this was although a lie
they knew that hunter was a sleazebag
trying to profit off his father's
high-powered government position
they knew that these emails potentially
put joe biden's candidacy at risk
in a close election and if the roles
were reversed stelter
and all these other media marvels would
have left no stone unturned to hold
trump accountable
of course the media and their democrat
colleagues
had to throw sand in your eyes though so
you wouldn't even see the story
they either didn't didn't cover it at
all or they went to their
trump era default mode they blamed
russia
this whole smear on joe biden comes from
the kremlin
every intelligence professional i've
been talking to mika says this is a
russian intelligence disinformation
campaign
it could have come from russian military
uh hacking
of a ukrainian gas company where hunter
biden served
rudy giuliani was dealing with alleged
russian intelligence agents
rudy giuliani is effectively a russian
asset at this point
this is what they were doing grasping at
straws
and in case that didn't work to keep the
scandal at bay they had to inject
covid into the biden story in an attempt
to kill it
trump is spending the week trying to
make hunter bide in a thing and and sort
of downplaying covet we're kind of past
the point where the president is going
to
take advice on covet 19 which is why
they're bringing in some of these other
topics like hunter biden the truth is
that we are in the middle of a pandemic
instead of debating crowd size or
unverified claims or conspiracy theories
we should be talking about policy
values and ideas
okay again it was publicly reported on
october 21st that biden's laptop
had been seized by the fbi back in 2019.
now it doesn't take a legal savant to
know that this is
a big deal and it's when they
should have started to ask a lot of
questions
just look at how the media six weeks
after the election
has changed its tune on this conspiracy
theory involving biden's son
remember this october 19th headline from
politico saying the hunter biden's story
is merely
russian disinformation according to
dozens of former intel officials
well politico now says the justice
department's interest in hunter biden
covered more than taxes then there was
nbc's pathetic pre-election misdirection
how a fake persona laid the groundwork
for a hunter-biden conspiracy deluge
but this was their headline today hunter
biden tax inquiry focused on
chinese business dealings and we
shouldn't forget
that major assist that twitter and
facebook gave the biden campaign
blocking
any sharing of that original new york
post
exclusive on hunter you got to hand it
to these people
they play for keeps ethics and truth be
damned
they couldn't risk any negative story on
biden getting any traction in october
they lied and they covered it up they
maligned real reporters who were
actually doing their jobs
and they left american voters in the
dark to protect their feeble candidate
and now they expect us to see them as a
check on the biden administration
i think we need a fact check and that's
the angle